Today, we're going
to be taking a look at
how bulletproof stickers can be,
and how many it takes
to stop a bullet completely.
[Music]
Guys, we have stickers,
which are apparently being
applied to my arm right now.
We give them out every once
in a while in meet and greets and stuff.
They've got the cool King
of Random crown logo on them,
and we wanted to do a test.
We have got lots
of these stickers,
hundreds of them,
and we are going to see how many
it takes to stop a bullet.
Here's the basic idea.
We're going to take a bunch
of stickers stacked up,
and with three different guns,
we're going to see
how bulletproof they are.
So we can stack them
up in a hundred,
and then if we decide
that we're going to need more
than that to stop one
of these bullets,
we can see just
how many it's gonna take.
We also have a few
different sizes of guns,
so we can try a couple
different things to see
less powerful bullets,
and more powerful bullets.
[Music]
We've made these stacks
of 100 stickers.
That's about how thick they are.
So just over
a centimetre I'd say.
We've got lots of those,
and we built
this nice little jig
that should nicely hold
our stickers in place.
So we're just going to start
by taking this hundred pack,
put it in the back, and see
if we can shoot through it.
We're going to go
with the lowest caliber we have.
We're gonna use a .22 rifle.
I think it'll get through that.
.22's aren't very powerful
as guns go
but I still think it'll get
through this pack
of a hundred stickers.
Here we go, first test.
100 stickers and
using the .22 rifle.
You guys, ready?
Yep.
Firing.
[Music]
First shot, I hit the stickers,
and they launched up
in the air somewhere.
They're back there.
And they landed in the snow.
And I thought I saw
where they landed,
but when I went to try
and find them, I couldn't.
So we're gonna try this again,
and at least try and keep track
of where they go.
Shot number two.
EG237818323KR
That went straight back.
[Music]
Well, the stickers
went right here.
Yeah.
Wait, did a hundred work?
It might have.
Oh, no.
I don't think there's
an exit wound.
Wait, There's a bullet.
You caught a bullet
with the hundred stickers.
You knocked the
backboard right off.
It's a .22,
but you still caught a bullet
with a hundred stickers.
Here we go.
[Music]
That's awesome.
That is our bullet.
[Music]
And then here we've got stickers
that I don't think they really
got pierced by the bullet,
but it like,
it just broke from the force
of the impact.
It looks like this sticker
is honestly like,
I wouldn't have thought
a sticker could get halfway,
but like there's
a tear in the front.
But it's not torn all
the way through at the back.
So this got stopped
by that last sticker.
That's, that's the bulletproof
sticker right there.
And this is really
interesting to me.
>> Like it just hit this hard enough.
>> And it exploded.
You could actually see
where you screwed
that into place.
The back of this
just tore right off.
Yep.
It broke right at the screws.
We may be improvising are back,
because one more shot,
and that whole thing
is going to come off.
I'm sure of it.
So we'll just end up
bracing it with some,
like a 2x4 and some rocks.
So we shot there nearly
a hundred stickers
with our .22 caliber.
Now, we're going to try
our hand gun with 500.
Let's see how far we go.
We are using
a more powerful gun.
And since we almost got through
with the weakest gun,
we're scaling it up,
a lot more stickers.
See how many we can get through.
So each one of these little
paper tabs represents
where we're at a hundred.
So we've got 500 stickers here.
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
[inaudible] right there.
This is about half of them.
These stickers don't have
any bullet damage.
I don't know
where the rest went.
Well, it looks like we lost 200.
So we can just put 200 back on.
[Music]
That's awesome.
I think the bullet
might have bounced out.
Because here we
have an impact,
and then where it stops.
Like we've stopped going
through stickers at this point.
But these ones,
like I can see right
through that one.
There's a hole.
Hello.
I can see you.
You can't see me though.
So yeah, we got through.
So that's I think a hundred.
200.
That's about a hundred,
and then I don't know
how it escaped at the bottom,
but it did.
The bullet is gone.
Oh, I think I see the bullet.
Right there.
So I think it went through,
and then the stickers
pushed it enough.
Okay, so maybe stickers
aren't bulletproof,
but their bullets deflecting?
Yeah, maybe.
Ready?
[Music]
How many did we get through?
At least a hundred,
and then it was still working
its way through the others
when I think I
got deflected again.
[Music]
Through some stickers,
out of the back
of this piece of wood,
and I believe I see,
at least part of the bullet
embedded in our 2x4.
Oh, yeah.
Look at this.
[Music]
Check this out.
Bullet scraped, bounced
off the back.
Holy cow.
As it took off that direction.
Well, this little handgun,
and when I say little,
I mean physically.
The handle of the gun is quite
small and hard to hold onto,
it's kind of hard to aim.
So I think we're going
to upgrade one more time
to a more powerful rifle
that should be easier
to aim well.
[Music]
All right.
That is 1000 stickers.
All sticked together
in like a sticker log.
All right, and for this,
we are going to be
using our AR-15,
the most powerful
gun we have here.
If we can get it
to stay in our holder,
which has been taking
some bullet damage, and...
[Music]
That should be fine.
We have used a lot of stickers
in an attempt to hold the rest
of our stickers in place.
I don't really think
it's gonna do much
against the power of a bullet.
But it was really fun.
Maybe it'll help a little.
We'll see.
Firing.
[Music]
Did I miss?
I'm not even 10 feet away.
Those cites were
lined up perfectly.
I think I shot over it.
I think it's cited for like
to be farther down range,
and I'm so close
that I'm shooting right over it.
All right, firing.
[Music]
And now it shoots high.
Bring me more bullets.
Nailed it.
Yes.
[Music]
Oh my gosh.
Here's the crazy thing though.
They shot at the back.
Right through.
There's our two bullet holes.
Was this the back one then?
I think so.
They just got like
smashed up against it.
But yeah, I think
that went--
Look at that.
It's actually held it
in place for you.
I think we shot
through a thousand stickers
with this rifle.
So you can see
the few holes there?
The two holes there.
This was the the back
piece I believe.
But when we have
that lined up right,
that shot through
1,000 stickers.
That kind of shows
off the difference
between the .22 and the AR-15.
The 22, stopped by 100 stickers.
Whereas the AR-15,
shooting .223 bullets,
got through a thousand.
Like I can clearly see right
through that hole too.
That actually is really cool.
Like I like that.
This is a design.
It's nuts.
Can a 1,000
stickers stop bullet?
Well, yes, and no.
It depends what bullet
and what gun.
.22 rifle, not so much.
The handgun didn't seem to get
through more than
about 250 stickers.
But our rifle with the .223 ammo
got through a thousand,
and carried on through the back.
Goodness golly gee.
It might have kept on going
right through the 2x4 as well.
Goodness golly gee?
Goodness golly gee.
Yes.
And most importantly,
our sticker bridge...
It actually--
Held our stickers in place.
But I think we should attribut
it to the sticker bridge.
I think this sticker
bridge actually worked,
and it was hilarious,
because all the other
ones went flying.
These stayed.
So can you fire
through a thousand stickers?
Yes, you can.
Does a sticker bridge
hold it in place?
Yes, it does.
Oh, that's hot.
That's hot.
Guys, that's not all.
We've always got more
for you see.
That box up with the top
will take you to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you hit this
bomb the middle,
you'll be subscribe
to our channel,
and that way, you'll
never miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.